assalam alaykum brother Zakir my name is
Saia I'm a revert Muslim the question is
in your lecture you mention the
scientific facts from the Quran which
have been
established can you mention a few
quranic verses which science has not
confirmed this the
question that I mentioned my
the scientific facts which science has
already established which mention in the
Holy Quran can I mention some few points
in the Quran which science has not
established for example the Quran
says in Surah shur chapter 42 verse
number 29 it says it is Allah who has
created the Heaven and the Earth and put
creatures living creatures throughout
them Quran says there is life besides
this Earth Allah has put living
creatures throughout the heavens and the
Earth there's no scientific evidence
established scientific evidence that
there is life beside this Earth recently
they have been sending rockets and
spaceships to different planets
different satellites Etc and now just a
couple of months
earlier we read in the newspapers that
they got certain material for Ms which
gives proof that life can be there in Ms
and in I think day for yesterday's paper
I read in times of India that they have
found water in the Moon maybe a comet
crashed and there's a big crater and the
water has been frozen to ice so in
future it will be easier to
investigation we do not have to take
water from planet Earth to Moon water is
already present there we can use that
water and it will save us a lot of
trouble science is saying there are high
possibilities of life being there
besides Earth but since Quran says I
believe in it maybe after one or two
years they may discover their life
beside this Earth or maybe after 50
years today
scientists they have given various
views how will our Earth end some
scientists have given a description that
the mountains will fall down some
scientists say the mountains and rock
will become smooth when the earth is
destroyed some people say the ocean will
swell up some people say the universe
will go in a black hole
several Quran too gives a description
about the day of judgment how will a
creation end
[Music]
many of them match with the theories of
science theories not established facts
for example the Quran says in
Surah 46 verse number three it is Allah
who has created the heavens and the
Earth for a limited period of time
giving you indication that this creation
will be destroyed and gives various
signs in the Quran for example if read
Sur 75 verse number 8 and9 it says that
the moon will be buried in darkness the
sun and the moon will join
together before our world ends if you
read Surah 81 verse number 1 2 3 and
verse number six it says that the sun
will be folded up the Stars will fall
down the ocean will swell up the
mountain will fall down in not a
ruin Quran says in infar 82 verse number
1 2 and 3 it says the sky will be C
asunder the star will be
scattered the mountain will fall down
where is signs how will the earth end is
given these are scientific points
mentioned in the Quran which science
hasn't established yet for
example the Holy
Quran also says in Surah Amia chapter 21
verse number 104 that as we created this
creation we will roll up the Heavens
like a Ro is rolled up and as we created
the early creation we shall create a new
creation so Quran says there is one more
New Creation that's going to be created
after the world is destroyed science
doesn't know about that Quran says the
first man on the Earth was Adam Alam
science hasn't discovered that yet Quran
speaks about Soul s hasn't established
that human beings have got soul the Holy
Quran also speaks about Gins about
spirits about angels sence hasn't able
to discover that Quran speaks about life
after death science discovered that
Quran speaks about heaven and hell
science discovered about that but you
may ask me the question brother Zak you
have given such a good lecture speaking
about scientific facts and you believe
in jins you believe in angels you
believe in Soul you believe life after
death aren't you illogical I will say no
I'm not a logical I have got a logic why
I believe I don't blindly believe in
life after death in the soul in heaven
and hell in gyms and Spirits I have a
logical
belief I based my logical belief saying
that Suppose there are scientific facts
mentioned in the Holy Quran out of which
say Approximately 80% have been proved
to be 100% correct 80% of the scientific
facts mentioned in the Quran have been
proved by science till today to be 100%
correct the remaining 20%
is ambiguous unknown not even
0.1% have been proved false even if one
vers is pro
false the Quran is not the word of Allah
subhana so these 20% I say goes in the
ambiguous slot unknown so my logic says
when 80% is 100% correct the remaining
20% is ambiguous out of which not even
01 person has been proved wrong all are
unknown my logic says 80% is correct
even those 20% will be inshallah correct
it's not a blind belief it's a logical
belief the next question please my name
is Muhammad Sadat I am a chemical
engineer in Hindustan Petroleum in Quran
it is mentioned that it is Allah who
decides the characteristics and the
personality of a person inside his or
her mother's womb in the field of
genetics this field has advanced so much
that nowadays parents can tell or make
their children if they want to have a
very bright student they can have it by
just having that genetic code changed
isn't this contradictory with
Quran the Brother P the question that
today genetics field has advanced and
it's possible that we can change the
genetics of of the child that is going
to be born Quran says that Allah is one
who shapes who forms I do agree with
that Quran say in several places says so
does it not mean it's cont the Quran no
but that is not when it gives the
statement Quran says without the power
of Allah it is not possible without the
power of Allah it is not possible at all
for example Quran says in Surah Rahman
55 verse number 33 that with power and
skill you will be able to penetrate the
heavens and the Earth not without the
permission of Allah wa tala you will
penetrate the heavens and the Earth but
only with permission Allah subhana wa
tala so today because people are going
in the heaven that does not mean the
Quran is wrong Quran says you can do but
with the permission of Allah subhana
tala without permission of Allah subhana
wa taala it's predicting that people
will go in outer space in Moon Etc but
if Allah doesn't want it cannot happen
and we know the incident of Challenger
the Challenger tried to take off what
happened he tried to challenge Allah
subhana tala what happened nothing
even today we say Family Planning do you
know there's no family planning which is
perfect even if you do tubet Tommy or W
Tomy if Allah wants he can yet bring
easy conception to that lady even if she
practices permanent method like tuek
Tommy or the husband does v Tommy still
there are chances but negligible chances
that the baby can be born if Allah
wishes no one can stop you do any family
planning method in genetics also if they
able to change it's with Allah's
permission if Allah doesn't want you
cannot change at all so few people are
successful all are unsuccessful those
who are successful are with the
permission of Allah subhana tala those
who are not Allah has not given them
permission same way Family Planning
those who are successful Allah gives
permission those who are not successful
Allah doesn't give permission hope to
answer the
[Applause]
question asalam alikum Zakir I was a
Hindu first and I converted into Islam
recently what I would like to ask you a
question is this that when a woman is
carrying a baby in a womb Islam forbids
abortion but if a woman is facing some
kind of a medical problem if she's
anemic or if she has just delivered a
baby recently in recent months to come
and there's always a threat to her life
non-muslims doctors say to abort it and
when the Muslim doctors say it is Haram
and someone who's a little bit modern
has said that if the child is for 40
days in the womb before 40 days you can
it after 40 days it is not possible
you cannot do it under Islamic law is
that right or is that wrong the brother
ask a
question that is speaking that today
scientifically the doctors who want to
abort Etc why does Quran does not give
permission to
abort if it's danger to the life of the
mother Quran speaks about abortion in
Surah Anam 6 verse number 151 as well as
in Surah isra 17 verse number 31 it says
kill not your children for want of
sustainance for it is Allah that will
provide sustainance to you and your
children for killing of infants is a
major sin so abortion is Haram under
normal circumstances for example pork is
Haram alcohol is Haram having dead meat
is Haram but same time the Quran says in
four different places in Sur Bak 2 vers
number 173 in Sur ma number 5 verse
number 3 in Sur Anam 6 verse number 145
and 16 verse number 115 it says that if
unwillingly if you disobey Allah subhana
wa tala Allah is rman if under
compulsion if you disobey Allah subhana
wa taala Allah is Rim if you're dying of
hunger porke is the only dish that you
can have pork becomes Halal for you it's
perfectly but don't have so much and
keep on having after you don't require
it if you in a jungle if pork is the
only thing that you can find to eat or
in a desert for becomes allowed for you
only for that time when you come back to
the city it becomes Haram the same way
abortion just because you don't want a
child is Haram in Islam it's a major sin
but if it's a danger to the life of the
mother it's totally allowed because in
Islam the life of the mother is more
precious than the life of the child
which has not come in being on its own I
do know there are certain people who say
that after 40 days it's not allowed
Before 40 it's
allowed Quran is very clear that if it's
a danger to your life unwillingly if you
disobey Allah subhana wa ta'ala it's
totally allowed so if the doctor say
that you have certain heart problem and
the labor pains will cause a strain on
your heart the mother will die you have
to AB about you have to go ahead with it
because in Islam you cannot sacrifice a
greater loss to save a small loss the
life of the mother who's already alive
and adult is more important than the
child who cannot live on its own so in
these cases if it's a danger to the life
of the mother it's totally allowed in
Islam if it's not a danger it's Haram
hope to answer the
question the next question from the lady
side salum brother Zakir um my question
is when Quran speaks so much about
science then how come the Muslims are so
backward in the field of science
the sister POS a question that when
Quran speaks so much about science how
come the Muslims are backward sister I
would mainly blame the
media the media today is in the hands of
the westerners the Europeans it's in
their hand they have the satellite they
have the television they have the CNN
they have the BBC it's in their
hand the media is in their hand and
whatever you read in your school books
and books which you read in college
you'll read there that from 8th to the
12th century it was a dark
ages dark for whom it was dark for the
Europeans not for the world the Arabs
and the Muslims were very much Advanced
from the 8th to the 12th century they
were very much Advanced the Europeans
were backward because they were backward
they said it was dark ages for the world
it was not dark for the world it was
dark for the Europeans with the limited
instruments and Technology what we had
from 8th to 12th century what
discoveries the Muslim scientists have
made it's unbelievable today because
science is Advance are making so many
Discovery there with the amount of
limited facility we had the amount of
discoveries Muslim scientists made it's
unbelievable for example I quoted in my
talk
thatf he discovered the blood
circulation but in the medical book
and the books we read in school who
discovered blood circulation
Willam everyone knows Willam Mai no one
knows about
Naf Naf spoke about blood circulation
400 years before the Europeans they
later on picked up the books of the
Muslims and rehashed it and said we
discovered it see if you see the
discovery that Muslims have made for
example if you know Ali in 1154 he drew
the first
map of Mediterranean the geography of
the world
first
mathematics Muslims were far advanced in
mathematics we introduce the decimal
points do you know what we call the
digits 1 2 3 it's called as Arabic
numerals the other ones are called as
Roman numerals why it called Arabic
numericals because the Arabs are the one
who discovered it the decimal point are
the Arabic
numerals the person who first proved the
Pythor theorem he was arusi we know
about the Pythor theorem know about
alusi he said that the square of the
hypotenuse was equal to the sum of the
opposite two sides of the
triangle aluni he was an authority in
trigonometry all these people they were
experts if you know of alindi alindi he
was a philosopher a mathematician and
astronomer when great scientists like
Galileo Newton Etc they said that all
physical laws were absolute he said that
all physical laws are relative and today
we know the theory of relativity is
proved by Albert Einstein no one know
about alindi he was the person who
basically gave the idea of theory of
relativity later on he did more research
and talked about theory of
relativity who knows about the Three
Brothers Muhammad Shakir and Hassan who
know about them they told the surface
area of the Earth from an angle at the
Red Sea when people thought the world
was flat
chemistry the Muslim the far advanced in
chemistry ja they have latinized the
word gabber so when we read in our
textbook gabber we think it's an
European it's a Muslim
ja we know gabber we don't know who
jabir he's the person who disted alcohol
alcohol comes from the Arabic word alul
meaning ghost evil spirit Al that Arabic
word he wrote 2,000 different pages of
only in
chemistry Muhammad zakar razi he was
famous in medicine he was Authority on
the field of small pox and
measel he was the first person who use
mercury onment he wrote books on
children's
disease there are several Muslims and Al
Abbas he wrote 20 volumes on medicine
Alina known as AA Aina it doesn't sound
Muslim Al Muslim not Muslim
who got the title of Asal of the East he
wrote the book
Canon which was referred as a textbook
of medicine till as late as 17th
century who knows
iur he was the person after Alexander
who research the parasitology he
described The Hite the pericarditis he
described oitis media he attack the
sty several medical alari alari was was
a famous dentist as well as surgeon as
as well as optician he invented several
instruments of
surgery
Gynecology as well as
Dentistry we all of us know the other
thing but the media is in the hands of
the westerners the Muslims are fire
advance but I do agree with you today
today the Muslims are getting backward
in science you know why the Europeans
are being Advanced you know why the
Muslims are becoming backward because we
are going away from the Holy Quran we
are going away from the
religion and do you know why the
Europeans are getting Advanced they too
are going away from the
religion the
europein are also getting Advance
because me they are going away from the
religion the Muslims we are going
backward because they're going away from
religion I would request the Muslim
brothers and sisters out here as well as
non-muslims they are people reading the
Quran why don't we read the Quran with
understanding why don't we ponder over
the verses we have only kept the Quran
kissing and giving on top that's
all the Quran was not meant only to be
kissed on kept on top it should be
implemented in your daily
life if you implement the Quran in your
daily life lead with understanding
inshallah again we will be on top of the
world hope the
question now we would give I would
request our volunteers to give
opportunity to any non-muslim brothers
and guests we have here at our mics to
give them a preference and opportunity
and then our other brothers I am K mahes
from lecturer from sabik po Technic in
the computer Department I would like to
ask regarding the Muslim marriage system
why Islam allows more than one woman to
be married with a man the brother POS a
question that why does Islam allow a man
to marry more than one wife Quran is the
only religious book on the face of the
Earth which says marry only
one there's no other religious book on
the face of the Earth whether you read
the ramayan the Mahabharat the bhagat
Gita the Bible no religious book says
marry only one except the Holy
Quran the Holy Quran says in Surah n 4
verse number three it says marry of a
choice in twos threes or fours but if
you can't do justice marry only one if
you can't do justice marry only one
otherwise if you can do justice Quran
has put an upper limit two three or four
maximum four not more than that previous
religions they gave permission for a man
to marry as many Vives as you want Quran
put an upper restriction of Maximum four
you know why because if you think
logically if you
analyze but it says at the same time
time in Surah n 4: 129 it is difficult
to do justice between your
wife it's difficult therefore do not
turn away from them altogether marrying
more than one wife you don't get more
Saab you don't get more
blessings there is no Hadith saying that
if you marry more than one wife you get
more
Saab there's a Hadith which says that if
you marry you complete half your Dean
somebody asked me a question at the time
does it mean if I married twice I
complete my full de
no marriage takes you away from
promiscuity from fornication therefore
it is far but whether you marry one or
two yet you're only completing half your
de the reason why Islam gives
permission for polygen that's the right
word is because if you analyze men and
women are born in equal
proportion but in the Pediatric age
itself since the female is the stronger
sex medically if you ask any pediatri
he'll tell you the female can fight the
germs and disease much better than the
male so more female children live than
the male children there are more deaths
in the male children than female
children when you grow up there are
accidents dead due to cigarette smoking
dead due to war more male die than
female war in Afghanistan do you know
more than a million people died mainly
they were gens whatever it is whatever
you said more men die than female if you
analyze the statistics India is one of
the few countries in which there is more
male than female you know why because of
female and
pde every day 3,000 fetuses are being
aborted when they identified that they
females more than 1 million aborted
every year in India on being identified
they female that's the reason otherwise
if you see the statistics of America
there are more than 7.8 million females
than males in America alone in New York
alone there is 1 million female more
than male and out of the population of
New York oneir are gay sodomite
K there are more than 25 million gays in
America that means there are more than
30 million females who can't find
husband in America
alone in UK alone there are 4 million
female more than male in Germany Alone 5
million female more than male in Russia
Alone 7 million femal more than male and
Allah subhana tala alone knows there are
how many million females more than males
in this world I'm asking you a question
that suppose my sister or your sister
happens to live in a America and suppose
everyone agrees with your philosophy
that every man should marry one wife and
every man in America marries a woman
still there will be 7.8 million females
and plus since the gays also don't get
married there will be more than 25 to 30
million females who can't find husbands
if my sister happens to be one of those
unfortunate lady who has not been
married and the market is saturated the
only option remaining for my sister is
to marry a man who already has a wife or
become public
[Applause]
property the next question from a
brother on the left alaykum my name is s
an Allah subh created
everything some vers say we created we
pre prepared like this why plural is
coming the Brother P the question that
why has the the word v used in the Quran
for Allah subhana wa tala is it more
than
one brother V in
Arabic the two types one is V for plural
one is Royal
plural Royal plural like for example if
you know the Rajiv Gandhi how you to
speak you to
say that H was not plural it was
singular it's a royal plural it's called
the same way Allah subhana wa ta'ala
some places I some places uses V the v
in Arabic does not indicate plurality it
means Royal plural actually singular so
we when it says we have created you it
means singular Allah subhana wa taala
Quran clearly states in suras 112 verse
number
one say he is Allah one and only Allah
is only one not more than one hope the
answer the
question assalamu alaikum brothers and
sisters I would like to know whether
organ transplant and organ donation are
permitted in
Islam the sister POS a
question that is organ transplantation
or donation allowed in Islam or not
there's no worse in the Holy Quran
directly saying that whether you should
give or you should not give it's silent
on that issue there were various
conferences taken place by various
throughout the world including in
Malaysia in jeda in Riyad even here on
this issue where organ transplantation
is allowed or Not by the consensus of
theas of the world today they say that
organ transplantation is allowed if you
satisfy the three conditions first is
the organ that are going to give to the
person the person if he receiv receives
the
organ his life will be saved only if his
life is in danger and then if he wants
the organ then it's allowed Point number
two the person donating the organ you
should not do it for economical reasons
not for
money not for getting one lakh rupees or
two lakh rupees third is after the
person donates the organ it should not
cause loss of his life today science
tells that there are certain organs in
the body for example the kidney one
kidney is sufficient for a human being
to survive and lead a normal life the
second is an
additional suppose my mother if she has
both the kidney failure and if I donate
one kidney surely Allah will not hold me
responsible so but natural if it doesn't
cause a loss to my life I can't say I
want to rate my heart if my heart is Tak
on I'll die so I can't donate my heart I
can only donate those organs which will
not cause
loss loss to my life and I should not do
it for economical reasons Point number
two and third it should save the life
this is the consensus ofas of the
conference that took place in Malaysia
in Riyad in jeda in India in India the
were reluctant but now if
you ask the F Academy of India even they
say it should not be done but if it is
used to saving the life as a lost Resort
you can give your organ as a donation
hope the anwers the
question the brother on my right good
evening everybody I'm a student of Sab
sidik my name is haraga I want to ask a
question
that after the death of human being dead
body should be B burned out or should be
buried the Pres P the question that
after human being dies should his body
be burned or should it be buried let's
analyze scientifically which is more
appropriate brother I told in my talk or
in the question answer time I believe
that the elements the consent of human
beings is present in lesser or greater
quantity in the soil in the earth so we
are created from Earth we should go back
to Earth it's logical more easier for us
to go back into the Earth Point number
one point number two is that if you burn
a body there is pollution there's
environmental hazard environmental
hazard is there when you bury a body
there's no environmental hazard in fact
the place where you bury Point number
three the ground and the surrounding
ground becomes more fertile
Point number four it is very cheap to
bury you don't require any money Earth
is freely available that are graveyard
but to cremate to burn you require tons
and tons of wood therefore every year if
the statistics our government goes in
loss of millions of rupees because
they're burning wood loss to environment
environmental problem Hazard and plus
waste of money if you calculate the
amount of people that are dying amount
of people you're burning it's a loss of
money has to the environment is much
more logical and scientific to bury the
body than to burn hope the answer the
question I would uh after the next two
questions are over I will allow some
questions on slips I'm told you some
ladies would have written questions on
slips they would not like to ask on mic
or there are some other people also so
we'll allow some questions the questions
which have come on slip can be passed on
to me uh after the question and unless
if there is some brother who's a
non-muslim I have told them they have
not had enough opportunity so that we
will make an exception to that they can
ask on the mic otherwise I read
questions from the slip after the next
two questions are
over asalamu alaykum my name is khid and
I am a student it's mentioned in Quran
that sun and other planets revolve and
rotate in a fixed orbit and at other
place relating to the Dooms Day it's
mentioned that Earth will collide with
sun in somewhat a SP spiral form when
revolution and rotation can uh then the
phenomenon of collision takes place how
is it possible the brother POS a
question that it says that the Sun and
the Earth rotate and some places say Sun
and the Earth will collide some places
says that but as I told you there are
certain statement in the Quran talking
about the signs of the day of judgment
and I myself quoted in Surah 75 vers
number 8 and 9 that the sun and the moon
will joined together when on the day of
judgment not today it's giving you signs
of day of judgment it's not telling you
that today it will happen the name of
the Surah Surah day of resurrection and
give various signs that the moon will be
bured in darkness the Stars will fall
down the ocean will swell up Etc these
are signs of the day of judgment has it
happened no but before the world ends it
will surely happen hope the answer the
question nowhere does the Quran a normal
circumstance will
happen one question I'll ask now on the
slip then on the mic one on the slip
then on the mic the question on the slip
is it
is mentioned in one verse of the Quran
that Allah is the lord of the two East
and two West how can you explain this
verse of the Quran
scientifically the question POS was that
the Holy Quran mentions that Allah is
the Lord of two East and two West how
can you explain scientifically what the
person is referring to is a verse in the
Holy Quran from chapter number 55 verse
number 17 which
says that Allah is the Lord of two East
and two West in Arabic we have two types
of plural one is dual plural and one is
plural more than two
yeah is dual plural that Allah is a lord
of two East and Lord of two
West let's see what science have to say
about that and we know
that the sun rises from the East and it
sets in the
west but science tells us today that the
sun rises from the due east only on two
days exact East in the other times if
you not is the point of rising of the
Sun keeps on vearing it rises exactly
due east only on two days the two days
of Equinox all the other days it either
Rises south or north of
East
similarly it rises from one extreme of
the east in the summer solstice and
rises from The Other Extreme of the east
in witer
solce similarly the Sun sets in Due West
only on two days on two days of Equinox
all the other days it either sets south
or north of Due
West it sets in one extreme of West in
the summer solstice and sets in The
Other Extreme of West in the winter
solstice so when the Quran says that
Allah subhana wa ta'ala is the Lord of
two East and two West it is referring to
the two extreme points of East and two
extreme points of
West but there's another verse in the
Holy
Quran in Sur Mar chapter number 17 verse
number 40 which says that Allah is the
Lord of easts and wests it is not dual
plural it is plural more than two Allah
is the Lord of East and the Lord of
West therefore Allah is the Lord of all
the various points in East so in short
Allah is the Lord of two extreme points
of East two extreme points of West and
all the points in between in the west
and all the points in between in the
East next question from the Ladi side
please Salam Alum brother Zakir my name
is Malika Muhammad Islam my question is
that what does the Quran mean when it
says that Allah sent down iron from the
heaven
the sisters as the question what does
the Quran mean when it says that Allah
has sent down iron from the heaven the
verse the sisters referring to the Holy
Quran is in Surah Hadid chter 57 which
means Aon verse number 25 which says
that Allah has sent down Aon in which
there is material for war and various
benefits for the human beings the Arabic
word used for send down is anzala it
means to sent down now anah can be
looked at in two different ways one way
is Allah has sent down Allah has
revealed so Allah has revealed that in
Iron there is a lot of use and material
for Mighty War as well as benefits for
humankind Allah has revealed this that
in Iron there's material for war and
various benefits and we know today that
iron is one of the most important Metals
we know of from it we get steel and
steel and iron is used for making
instruments of war like weapons swords
Spears Guns Etc it's even used for
making instruments of Peace like brick
layer instruments of an engineer
instruments of an architect knife forx
spoon Etc so if you read the first
meaning it says that Allah has revealed
that in Iron there is various benefits
and material for Mighty War the other
way if you take literally
that iron has been sent down been sent
down for heaven this verse was shown to
Professor
Armstrong that what do you have to
comment on Surah Hadid chapter 57 verse
number 25 he says that iron has been
sent down for heaven so he tells us that
it's recently that the scientists have
come to know about the formation process
of various elements and they say that
the energy required to make one atom of
iron it's so enormous that the energy of
the whole solar system is not sufficient
and a calculation was made that energy
four times that of the solar system is
made to produce one atom of
iron means the energy of the moon the
stars the sun all these energies we take
of the planets Etc of only the planets
of the solar system and the Sun and the
Moon it will not be sufficient to
produce prod one atom of iron scientist
today tell us that iron is an
extraterrestrial metal which is
confirming the quranic if you take it
literally that iron has been sent down
from the
heaven the next question from the
slip there was a philosopher in 6th
Century BC who said that the Earth
rotates about its own axis and the
planets move around the Sun the Quran
also gives the indication of a similar
scientific fact some people Alle that
the prophet copied these points from the
philosopher please
comment the question P
was that there was a philosopher in 6th
Century BC who said the planets and the
Earth would around the Sun maybe the
prophet copied from the philosopher
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him I do
age that in the 6th Century BC the
pythagoreans these people they defended
the theory
that the earth and the planets they
rotate and they revolved around the Sun
but to say that Prophet Muhammad peace
be upon Him copied from them is
illogical because these people fail to
realize that the same pythagoreans they
also defended the theory that the sun
was the center of the universe the sun
was fixed it did not rotate neither did
it revolve so to say that Prophet
Muhammad sallallahu Ali wasallam copied
those two points Earth and planets
rotate and they revolve and didn't copy
the point which says that the sun was
Center of universe the sun was fixed it
did not rotate it did not revolve is a
logical I do know that there are various
philosophers whose works of
antiquity gives us ideas and they say
several things but if you analyze The
Works of philosophers of antiquity their
works is mixed with invalid and valid
ideas people normally quote the valid
ideas they forget that they even left
behind invalid ideas they were great
thinkers the difference between these
philosophers who predicted and the Quran
is these philosophers only thought and
predicted and they made even false
statements the Quran alhamdulillah more
than 1,000 verses speak about signs and
not a single is wrong the difference is
Quran gives a challenge to say that
Prophet Muhammad saham copied from these
people and didn't copy the negative
point maybe one or two it's possible it
was FL but to say that all the thousands
of verses the Quran speaks about sence
the copied is illogical because Quran
gives a
challenge in 4 verse number 82 do you
not consider the Quran with okay had it
been from anyone besides Allah there
would have been many
contradictions the next question from my
brother on the
right assalam alayum my name is
Fel how scientifically or logically can
you explain that Allah subhana ta'ala
being omniscient that is knowing the
past present future and everything send
scriptures before the Quran why didn't
he send the Quran itself
brother have a
question that why did Allah subhana tala
did not send Quran earlier why he send
the other Revelations first and then the
Quran it's like you asking me that why
didn't you first teach me medicine why I
to go to standard one standard two
standard three and then do my medicine
you have to go in stage wise all the
previous Revelations that came before
the Quran as I mentioned earlier was
sent only for those people and for a
particular time
period the Holy Quran is sent for the
whole of humankind and it message is
meant till
eternity therefore the previous
Revelations they not been preserved
Allah thought it right he has Divine
knowledge he knows when to send the
final Revelation not that he could not
send
earlier like the teacher knows how much
to teach to a student should not go
beyond the level so Allah thought it fit
that the humankind maybe had reached
that level where I can reveal the final
Revelation Allah knew that maybe
previously the time was not right
therefore all the previous Revelations
none of them have been preserved except
the Holy Quran because Quran is the last
and final Revelation and it will prove
itself to be the word of God it proved
itself 1400 years ago will prove today
and will be able to prove to Eternity
inshallah the next question from the
slip the Quran says
that Allah has made the Earth for you as
a carpet this gives an indication that
Earth is flat which is contradictory
with modern
science the question posed
was and people astonished out
here that the Quran says the Earth was
sped out like a carpet so doesn't mean
it was flat what the person is referring
to is an A in the Holy Quran in Surah
chapter number 71 verse number 19 and 20
which does say
that we have spread out the Earth like a
carpet but it gives the answer in the
next verse in verse number 20 so that
you may walk and travel in the spacious
path as I mentioned my talk the geology
that tell us today the Earth which we
live on the surface is hardly 1 to 10
miles and less than 1% of the total
radius of the Earth which is 3,750 miles
the top layer is a solid shell the
deeper layers are hot and fluid and
inhospitable for existence of
life no way does the Quran say that the
Earth is flat it gives a similitude that
we have spread out the Earth like a
carpet people normally have
misconception that a carpet can only be
sped on a flat
surface it's wrong a carpet can also be
sped on a spherical surface for example
imagine that there is a big model of the
Earth the globe say about 10 ft in
radius very big very well you can spread
a carpet around it it's possible because
when we lay out a carpet we normally
spare out a carpet on the surface which
is not comfortable to walk on carpet is
normally Spar out on a Surface which is
not comfortable to walk on so science
today tells us that if the outer crust
was not spread out like a carpet around
the spherical Earth we would not be able
to live because the deeper layers are
hot and fluid so when Quran says we are
spad out the Earth it is refering to the
Earth's crust has been spread out like a
carpet and the reason is given so that
you may walk in the spacious path of the
Lord Quran says in other places also
that we have made the Earth as spacious
Quran says this 78 verse number 6 we
have made the Earth as an
expanse it is referring that the Earth
we have made as wide you know why the
answer is given in Sur kabut 29 verse 56
which says we have made the Earth as a
wide expans for you so that you will
worship me and me alone so tomorrow you
cannot say that the situation where I
lived in maybe Bombay it was a difficult
circumstances therefore I was prevented
to do good deeds and I did Evil Deeds
Allah says the Earth is a wide expanse
for you it is pacious you cannot give
the excuse for doing evil Deeds because
of your
circumstances therefore worship Allah
and Allah alone there's no place in the
Holy Quran which says the World is Flat
in fact I told you in my spe the Quran
says in man
31:29 and Sur Alum 39: number 5 that the
world is theorical and specifically in
Sur na 79 verse number
30 we have made the Earth thereafter egg
shaped like an ostrich egg which is
exactly GEOS sperical hope that answer
the
question next brother on my
left
Alum my name is Abdul Subhan I'm an
accountant
it is mentioned in
Quran that Allah tal says no one can say
what is in the stomach of mother male or
female but on the other hand science
says is proving male or female so kindly
give you light on this question brother
Paul the question that the Quran says
that no one besides Allah subhana wa
ta'ala can mention what is the sex of
the child and the mother's
and today science is Advanced we can
come to know by ultr sonography Etc the
sex of the child what the brother is
referring to a verse in the Holy Quran
from Surah lukman 31 verse number 34
which says only Allah has the knowledge
of the r of when it's going to rain what
is in the womb of the mother where will
a person die and what will he earn the
Quran says only Allah knows what is in
the womb of the mother it does not say
what is the sex of the child in the
mother's womb alhamdulillah
[Music]
[Applause]